i used to watch mike's fights and just
be like
oh man he is the are you watching on the
social world
fighting with [ __ ] m and then yeah
remember y'all are fighting and [ __ ]
yeah we gotta get into all that
i'll be watching these podcasts i'd be
very blessed
[Music]
you want me to bring her in mike go for
it
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot box and i'm evan britton and i'm
mike tyson
mike we got a great guest today awesome
guest and a friend too this is gonna be
some help
none other the viewing and the one and
only benzino
what's up boston's own brother what's up
man
champ man it's a pleasure honor this is
you know what i'm saying one of my idols
right here uh honestly and i
i ain't been the same since you you know
since you retired honestly to be honest
this is your day today man what is it
like listen
this is what this is what i was tripping
about when i said you was coming up
because i was just
not long ago looking at some youtube
[ __ ] about whitey bozier right
man wow so i'm saying to myself what
kind of [ __ ] is this you know
you look everybody looks up to him he's
a hell of a [ __ ] he's a badass he's the
baddest [ __ ] in boston there's
never been a ferocious savage gangster
like him before
and he's untold on everybody hold on
everybody he then told him the mob for
the cops to get rid of the mafia
take he was amazing listen
no gangster's ever done that played both
sides of the law it's never been done in
this
i mean in the crazy thing really when
they know me when they found him they
found him with 30 guns in his wall
imagine having to live like that your
whole life is terrified
with your woman and stuff living like
that yeah that's man that was
i mean they made like two three movies
about him yeah the departed was one
jack nicholson played him and then
johnny depp played and johnny good one
what movie was that black mask oh that's
right that's right yeah
i remember my father my father had to
run in with umbrella i know him and your
crew your father
didn't go to what go well yeah yeah my
dad had to run in with him on me i just
remember the story he told me um
was that it was him and uh his friend
jimmy
god rest jimmy and uh jimmy was like a
bank robber
and um i guess him and jimmy i don't
know if it was over a woman or whatever
but uh
they had some problems and it was in
southie and and i think they went to
whitey's you know the pool hall where
whitey was at and
i just remember my father saying that
when they got in there they had locked
the door behind him
but um he said that at the time it was
like three guys in there he said
jimmy had bluff like he had something
and he's like listen anybody move i'm
gonna give white he wanted to head so
you unlock that door
and my father said that they unlocked
the door they just took off got in the
car and he was shooting man shot shot
the car but they got up out of there but
that was the story with white
crazy life man yeah that's insane yeah
man my father made big up the schnapps
man my father
not she's not a hero you know what i'm
saying
growing up in boston
what was that like well you know
again i i was my father's son so my
father had a pretty
pretty you know solid reputation in
boston you know what i'm saying um
he dealt with some real solid guys up
there and i got to see that life at
a at an early age and um i mean you know
i i would go visit him in the feds and
you know he'd give me little notes and
i'd be taking the notes to other fair
joints and passing them off and i mean i
was
i was you know i'm saying i was young
you know he had me doing little things
out there so it was like
i got kind of exposed to life at an
early age and
you know boston what i realized was i
mean um
it's it was segregated you know like
with white ebola
still segregated pretty much yeah pretty
much yeah man i mean you know where
whitey was from
south boston and south boston's pretty
predominantly irish
and then like the north end was
predominantly italian
and then you know we're in roxbury in
dorchester and mattapan we're in the
hood but
you know it's it's you know 100 years
ago roxbury was all irish
right roxbury i mean almost the whole
boston yeah john l sullivan came from
roxbury massachusetts first heavyweight
champion
do you know where the term the paddy
wagon came from yeah from
um cops right it was for irish it was it
was it was for the irish that was called
the
cop they would call them the paddies so
uh there was
four of them but they were patty
whackers yeah yeah yeah patty whackers
yeah yeah yeah
yeah wow boston is a trip though you
know because yeah
i mean growing up as far as you know
people of color it's you know
i mean you really couldn't do too much
yeah difficult for you racist
yeah busting i remember a lot of times
you see
i always seen a tub in boston when when
um they were
busting roxbury people into okay white
areas i see them in total
oh yeah you could pull it up on youtube
see a lot of times when you pull up that
stuff you see
roxanne in the 50s 50s no 70s
70s 70s that [ __ ] was in color see
that's that's the whole crazy [ __ ] about
is that
that it was in color like they were
savages that you think these are yeah
being lost to humanity
i know i've seen these i've seen this
favorite bro they would they would
you would get on you would get on a bus
and they and you know and you would go
into these neighborhoods and they would
be little
young white kids like this throwing
rocks at the bus
like this like five years old man it's
so wild
because you don't think of you know a
city like
boston as having that history where they
hide it
right they hide it one of the most
secret boston's
yeah i love boston though i love boston
it's complicated it's complicated tough
you can't help with the love and you
can't help but love the um
what the people really stand for black
white whatever the people
they're hard hard tough people are tough
people yeah if they're with you to die
for you and kill for you it's real [ __ ]
yeah you know but they just don't [ __ ]
around nah he's right he's got one
chance to [ __ ] with them
and another thing is like [ __ ] like even
though boston might have been racist
like i didn't grow up
hating white people right you see what
i'm saying that's what's so crazy
because you know again my father
i know i met some real heavy italians
and different
men you know i'm saying that well you
know so i was i it's you know you see
you don't want you want to have the same
you want to be the same playing field
for black white and everybody so you see
where it's not the same playing field
but it doesn't make you
racist like you know what i'm saying
throughout my whole life i've always
been
hooked up somehow like you know even
with dave mays from the source you know
he's a jewish kid man and
yeah was with him all my life you know
so how did you get connected to him
because he was a harvard kid
right that's how he was going to harvest
i was in a group you know
gang banging doing my thing and we had a
group called the almighty rso
and we was wild as [ __ ] there's more
than hagglers from boston
he's like about a month the marvelous
one
um jackie marciano from brockton
same thing yeah marciano tough town man
yeah man tough times knock them
blockbuster brockton yeah brockton yeah
yeah there's a few champions in brockton
yeah a lot of boxing
so was that your introduction like mike
yeah man we need to look at that the
latest this is a great
the lighters evaporative it's crazy as
hell here i am doing
i used to watch mike's fights and just
be like oh man he is the
watching on the social worker oh he was
like you fighting with [ __ ] m and
then [ __ ]
man yeah remember y'all was fighting and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah we gotta get into
all that brother
i'll be watching these podcasts i'll be
back listen mike's man listen man i love
mike man for real man
mike you don't understand how like
pharrell like you don't understand like
you're like you probably do you probably
know but man dudes from the hood
if if there was no mike tyson i don't
know how dudes from the hood would
really get that
that motivation man because you've
motivated so many guys just to
be something to watch how you just went
about your business you didn't talk too
much man
you wasn't with all that rah-rah you
just go up in there and i know you know
what i'm saying
i don't think i've ever seen anybody
with a more lethal uppercut
like like you could just be right here
like a punch don't even come from here
just here
and just get the younger kids three
inches and just i just wanted
to go well you know i wanted to make my
mentor real happy i was one of those
guys that
my mentor adopted me and my whole
purpose was just to make him happy
man and made him happy with knocking
people out
yeah yeah the quickest i can do he
looked like a great you know honestly he
looked like a
from the you know from the documentaries
and everything like because the motto
looked like a great man
oh he's incredible yeah his wife he's
incredible he was um
he has had so many morals his moral to
the floor
you know man we got the painting of it
man
somebody who loves this artist who loves
the podcast behind him yeah that's big
man
right amazing i've been to the cats
because i actually recorded i recorded
some music up in the catskills yeah
went up there the boston's not far from
the catskills not too far at all you
just go straight 90.
yeah i'm saying you know we got some
strippers from seuss right they've shot
a video up there
we used to go on to holyoke
massachusetts and boxing where kids we
just go home
field massachusetts wow springfield yeah
regionals and then if you win the region
you go to boston to fight for the finals
and then i won the boston golden globes
and stuff damn i didn't know that
yeah i won the boston globe i didn't
know that when i first started in the
amateurs you know i had to get knocked
out to learn
too it happens to you but if you make
that mistake i don't care if you're the
strongest man in the world you make that
mistake
you never got knocked out the way you
knocked out me no no
i knocked off the knockout you know you
made a mistake and you got and
and it cost you that's what it's all
about not about being knocked out
right right you made that mistake and it
cost you yeah
what was some cost more than others
because man boy
yeah what was a knockout that you really
remember mike
when you got knocked the most oh when
you got knocked out i got nothing
all of them you know yeah
well i was never unconscious and stuff
yeah no i remember all of them yeah
what would happen you just stars
and then you pop up this is interesting
you never know what happens gonna happen
some guys um
they're boxing the boxing right boom
boom boy right they're knocked out
yeah they're out but they're fighting
wow really these [ __ ] out
yeah they got they got blows they're
knocked out
boom
still going yeah exactly exactly some
guys are fighting still fighting they
don't even know where that is
you're just all nervous have you ever
been worried or scared when you knocked
somebody out like damn like is he all
right like
you killed that guy like yeah yeah
sometimes you hit it up
and you don't feel it yeah like you
missed them
oh [ __ ] yeah that's a bad one
yeah the bad yeah it was bad that's
that's just clinging right through boom
how cold snoring
[Laughter]
sometimes you hit a guy and um
he's conscious everything's cool with
him he's not hurt but his legs he's
his legs yeah he can't stop his legs
i've seen that a few times he's cool
everything's good oh he's like
[ __ ] oh he's doing the macarena yeah
the body's not meant this is what um
human beings do our hands are not meant
for hitting
that's why they always break um our
body's not meant to be beat on right
that's how it's so easy for us to be
brain damaged detach retina and stuff
because our body is not meant for that
stuff right
it's amazing that some of our parts stay
together the way we get hit like yeah
football and stuff that we still have
our jawbone and stuff stays in there
that's
[ __ ] it's amazing that i [ __ ] do
it's just a little [ __ ] no
right thin [ __ ] piece that keeps it
together i can't believe it's not
going with somebody hit it yeah oh god
did you have a doctor
or you always worked with yes always a
doctor in my corner
keep a doctor in my corner for my cuts
anything always
try the best to have the best health as
possible because this is a funny
um business you see a guy get beat the
hell
all his life for 20 years gets bombing
get bash all this like
every fight is a bash and then he's
really articulate and talking well 20
years later and then you get a guy that
got hit one fight man guy had two or
three good times
and he's talking funny got you you know
it's just you don't i know how these
people work you don't know how life is
you don't know how people are structured
how their soul is structured their body
is structured we're all different
yeah that's what's strange yeah that's
really strange in every way
some of us well you know from let's say
a million years ago some of us are
descendants from
um hybrid species from mating with
moguloids or some other binding that's
right
right got you and we're built
differently they were structured
differently so i guess we're
deformly structured even though we think
we look perfect
you know who who who out of anybody that
you hit kept him was like damn he went
down after i hit like yeah where's your
hardest
hardest fight [ __ ] raid the running
holyfield [ __ ] jessie ferguson you mean
god you gotta [ __ ] well you gotta you
gotta
shoot these [ __ ] man so who's
the one the one
the one that you hit was like god damn
he ain't went down yet [ __ ] holyfield
holyfield yeah yeah the [ __ ] monks
so is that is that not everybody can
take the same punch too is that
different
is that all different it's not like or
is it like if you hit somebody in that
same spot everywhere they're all going
down oh listen
human beings and human spirits are
amazing right if you just look if you're
fighting with a guy and you don't win
we're in this fight and you [ __ ] [ __ ]
this [ __ ] he's great but [ __ ] we
gonna fight
so he's hitting you with some good shots
but you just resisting cause you're in
your [ __ ] you set your mind this
is what it's gonna be
right we're gonna fight i ain't going
down from his first time i'm gonna [ __ ]
it as mike types and we're fighting
you know what i mean and he's
anticipating these punches he's
anticipating these hard punches hitting
him right it's in his mind so they hit
him boom
it's not as hard as he thought they were
if i was right so he's fighting back
right and then he gets hit with a punch
that he doesn't say boom
he's out it's all about not seeing the
punch tricking the guy where he don't
see the punch like yo
boom and hit him with that punch anybody
could take a pole yeah you tough
boom if you see it coming boom he could
take it boom he could take it
it's all about having fake this one boom
and hit him that way about tricking him
who whom tactically did you watch coming
up tactically like
roberto duran
mean [ __ ] tactically yeah his
tactic game is a [ __ ]
it's beautiful it's the head his head
stop he shakes his head his face like
his room his head move putting his face
oh he's a master dancer it's in his
prime it's beautiful
that's amazing huh travis went
90 undefeated right yeah all right miss
if he retired then right crazy i think
he retired to 60 fights
undefeated he had 90. how could anybody
even
really i don't know our egos get big
when we come into reality and we look at
ourselves in the mirror and we say wow
what he did is amazing
incredible i'll never see it again in my
life right
you'll never see that i won't see it
again in my life nine yeah
alexis aguero guell had like a hundred
something wins yeah but not straight
that's right they had 90 straight wins
yeah i mean they don't do that anymore
no
i won't see him in my life you won't see
him unless you listen they don't think
they're incredible
he doesn't get the credit for that
either they don't do that no more
he fought anybody named him anybody it
was a problem man
anybody maybe they could do that in a.i
excuse me maybe they could do that with
the artificial intelligence oh shove
this fight duran yeah yeah
but listen peep game right imagine how
advanced we were
when we didn't have a telephone cell
phone and we had to remember all the
numbers in our head remember and
remember how to get something we had in
our head
yeah remember how we found we didn't ask
directions we have
got loads
you know what i'm saying so you know a
lot of times you get locked up now you
know nobody's number
who you gonna call you know what i'm
saying yeah but listen
it just works out even if you're in
prison things work out for the best and
when you think it's your worst next
thing you know
i'm out of myself how did i get myself
yes some crate somebody might say hey
you need this telephone call you need to
go to your social worker
you know it's not as bad as we all think
it is then when it does get bad
god prepares us in the handling anything
you know yeah that's right man the
chance it's all about not giving up in
life you know sometimes things are bad
but sometimes you just gotta
endure [ __ ] yeah you ever gonna run for
office
never [ __ ] think i gotta do my
[ __ ] cases and my [ __ ] would
vote for you in the heartbeat yo oh you
know [ __ ]
he definitely win the popular [ __ ]
there's no doubt about it any electoral
[ __ ] yeah i'm saying
oh yeah so what is boston about now
what's happening out there
i mean boston's new people huh you never
saw before but the problem with boston
is like
the powers that be kind of suppressed
the culture
so this is you know they don't you know
i mean this night it's not like strictly
um strictly white
town yeah man you can't really but you
got to be sports up there when it comes
to hip hop
see i had to get about i had a hard time
up there you know if i would have stayed
up there i always did a hundred years i
got killed either oh isn't that i don't
know
what i'm saying there was no question
man like it was just
it's hard it's hard being in a big city
and you know everybody knows you and
everybody you know i'm saying because
look
it's not it's not that hard for the
police just to watch you and
you know what i'm saying and and and try
to mess with you and that's what was
happening with me you know we had a rap
group but
we was in the streets and the police
gang for us i'm talking we
we got we was on tommyboy records and uh
did you know god
yeah of course yeah you knew him yeah
well that [ __ ] did a little business
with god i remember god from new york i
was thinking
you know that movie you know i met god
but i remember my friends knew god you
know the movie that they made that they
made about him right
that was that was intuitive a lot of
people didn't know that
yeah but they didn't shoot that in
boston though they shot it in like ohio
so that's what i'm saying like they
don't let you know like that could have
been cool for boston
people you know get some you know some
some roles and everything but everything
gets taken out the guy from new york
went up there
mentally he went up there took over a
project he started doing his thing yeah
yeah wow yeah yeah he wrote the book he
got
[ __ ] [ __ ] he got my name is
god there was another dude named god in
tucson who owned a bar
called the meat rack tell me what was
that about
[ __ ] crazy bar in tucson they had a
sex room in the back he had
he would give people a [ __ ] brand his
face on people's asses for
lifetime 50 cent drinks 50 cent beers
i always went to that trip i want to be
guarded i took that [ __ ] toad and i
realized
god is inconceivable we can't even
fathom being god
god won't even speak to us we won't even
hear our calls
god don't even need us matter of fact if
all of us died
god would be happy because the world
would flourish you know
that's deep we kill the world you know
we got a [ __ ] gas tank we drink drink
for our [ __ ] oils
we kill the [ __ ] ice caps over there
you see them same things that go like
this coming up the hills
where's that when we popped that uh uh
over
uh what was it height stuff
yes man they can't be no more oil than
their [ __ ] over there
why don't they get them [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is coming out of that [ __ ]
produces it it's like taking the [ __ ]
and pissing it comes out of the earth
that should look dry over there i'm sure
they're still getting something out of
that dude
you would not be on the let's be honest
right and this is
we don't know when the first when the
first hits or you know it gathers up and
it stands
how do we know it is this is dried out
or we don't know if it's dried out
it just looks like nothing comes from i
mean just the area just they would
listen they wouldn't be there if they
weren't getting no money
they got to be they wouldn't be there
these people are not stupid they're not
going to be there they're not getting no
money
yeah wasting manpower wasting energy
they don't want to waste money they want
to make money
yeah man boy i chevron refinery right
across the street i've seen that
i've seen a lot of run employees i've
seen that
yeah running the source what was this
like
i loved that when you did that you guys
put me on the cover when i came home too
that's so
dope serious coverage yeah great
coverage
tyson come on man wow dude yeah i got
out you
you know what i'm saying all right
that's how you i'm not good i'm not bad
i'm just trying to survive in this world
baby
it's tough out in this [ __ ] look
at that
huh amazing source baby before the
internet
yeah ain't that some [ __ ] yeah
before the internet
what is the source now is it still a
matter it's still it's still out there
it's it has no onus you know what i'm
saying but you know it'll never have the
yeah yeah though that was just the time
man that was you know for us that was
like
the wolf of wall street meets i mean i i
was just like you know like mike said
like i was just you know like i was a
street [ __ ] who just you know what i'm
saying i didn't know about all that
money man there was so much money coming
in and
i was doing amazing [ __ ] like it was out
of control man i was i was out of
control
yeah i ran billions man i was 20s in the
20s and then you know
[ __ ] you know i brought my whole team
with me so i was at
i used to be at the beverly hills hotel
and that bungalow in the back i
i didn't want to leave well i would stay
there for months run up couple hundred
thousand dollar bills
man i mean i mean it was it was it was
you know like he said a lot of women a
lot of drugs a lot of crazy [ __ ] man but
it was you know listen [ __ ] that's the
way it was
listen what's that guy scott carter
coker
right he's a bellator guy yeah so when
someone win
k1 at the time so this guy takes me
and he [ __ ] um he puts me up in the
hotel on wilshire boulevard what's that
the beverly wilshire right uh-huh
michael she from rideau yeah yeah so i'm
up here for like a year and a half
i could eat my food mr titan how are you
doing and how are you doing
i'm [ __ ] up this guy's paying all the
money because now i got to go to
thailand wouldn't i
go here i thought [ __ ] i'm on a drug
i'm going to cocaine
imagine getting having all the cocaine
you want and you got all the money you
want you almost feel like you're gonna
die and go to heaven
[Music]
like real talk man like it's a [ __ ]
trip [ __ ]
man life i'm yeah what a [ __ ]
trip dude yeah man i remember one time i
was at the beverly hills
you know and i you know i remember was i
was with child rule we was on
we was i think i was opening up for him
some or whatever so
a couple of beans and i never really
took ecstasy like that and [ __ ] so i
grabbed one this ain't nothing you know
what i'm saying that's right so i i'm
so i'm i'm calling over a girl you know
i'm saying to come on over so i took
another one
i must took lives like i don't feel [ __ ]
so i called him like yo he's the same
this
is whack you know what i'm saying
they're saying nothing i said i'm
getting better
then so i took like about six of them so
oh no
so look right i started going crazy then
i couldn't my [ __ ] jaw couldn't like
so then all of a sudden i couldn't move
so i was in the bed and i couldn't get
to the phone so i'm trying to
get to the phone so i'm trying i'm like
oh [ __ ] i'm getting scared at this point
right
so i get the car to the phone i'm in the
beverly hills [ __ ]
the bungalow [ __ ] so i get the cord and
i pull it over and i
i'm trying to dial this [ __ ] man it took
me like a half an hour i finally get it
and i remember bj and so i was like yo
y'all got to come here
i saw my dog i'm a dog they came out i
just remember them putting
they just went got a whole bunch of um
cold towels and [ __ ]
and put them on me in the bed and [ __ ]
like three days i was i'll never do that
[ __ ] again like
you know coke i sniff coke right just
like he said coke see with coke
coke you think you you gotta [ __ ] i'm
getting ready
i'm getting ready
like get me a wagon the girls is like yo
there's only so much i want some dick
like
don't go to a chill chill shut the [ __ ]
up with weight it's going to be all
right
it's all right though that's life it's
all good life is good and you learn you
never learn with me with me you'll never
do it again
i know i mean just in general with the
whole drug culture like when i grew up
you know i'd be 54 in july when i grew
up you know what i'm saying
it was everything for every drug that
came on the block what's this we trying
this
heroin we sniffing heroin what's crack
what's this new [ __ ]
black beauties uh quaaludes i mean we
you that's what it was back then it was
like like you selling them and then it's
like oh let's try it
most drugs ain't for everybody so like
you pick and choose your poison you know
what i'm saying
so but at the end of the day you know
drugs ravaged our communities we get it
yeah but it's like it's something that
we have to deal with like
like in our culture and you know with
drugs just like with money and
everything else like i was oblivious to
this [ __ ]
once we had the source and all this
money everything was coming fast
and i just was like [ __ ] it i thought
this was like i said it was like woeful
wall street
well it's an interesting yeah it's just
never gonna end
it's an interesting thing that mike's
brought up you know
since the beginning of time there has
been the phenomenon
of human beings taking substances to try
to feel
some certain way you know and so
you know it's just continued and
perpetuated because it's not i mean you
have you have
people who do drugs who just do drugs
and that absolutely i think people
who do drugs and just actually can just
function yeah that's hard see i see i i
think absolutely
is what is what a sexual thing comes in
you know what i'm saying yeah
with something i know what you mean no i
know what you mean for sure absolutely
why i was told the reason why
when you um when we get high like a
hurdle
when we get high we want to [ __ ] then
why because our brain tells us we're
dying and we have to meet
[Music]
is there research do you know that or is
that your theory
no that we're getting ready to die so we
want to mate we know it makes sense
or we want to mate or get enough we're
getting ready we're getting ready to die
so we need to um
spread our seeds that's what i think
listen we're just some
we don't understand we think we we think
we're we're we're driving this ship
we think that we're guiding our ship
right that way that we're doing we
really think that we're doing it but
it's always designed
if it wasn't designed for us to be here
we'd be dead by now no well i'm saying
everything's designed for us we think
that we're controlling me talking to you
right now
me talking to him i think that i'm i'm
smart and i'm telling you listen this is
just
the moment but yes this is the play yeah
this is already the script was already
it's already here yeah i mean i mean
yeah i mean i i don't know i just think
like see what the sex thing is
i always thought like if if we wasn't
ever
to have to have pleasure having sex i
think the world would be different
if pleasure and you know i mean if the
pleasure didn't come along with sex then
everything would be different well it's
interesting
what i'm saying because listen let me
tell you why if a lion
of a tiger could i mean if a tiger
doesn't if he see the um
the female tiger out of season they're
going to fight to the death
you're going to kill each other season
they're going to make love but obviously
they fight to the death you see the
tigers they're not supposed to
not even my family that's crazy yeah
yeah i see that wow i see that [ __ ]
outside of breeding season she's dead
what you doing on my territory huh
it's interesting that's our type of
thing it's crazy
wow that's crazy crazy yeah well human
beings and
dolphins i think are the only two
species that
experience pleasure with sex really get
the [ __ ] out of here
that's some truth dog monkey have to
they have to be a breed of monkey monkey
is the one yeah there's one yeah
i seen some dogs and they were smiling
when he was humping them
animals is species of animals it's not
99 of them have a certain
season when they [ __ ] yeah yeah you know
ants but we have a certain season
human beings and i think it's one
particular kind of monkey yes
it doesn't have a phenomena
yeah i'm cold just like human beings
yeah have no reason to [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah it's a particular species yeah
and the females are very sexually
oriented we're the only species that
does that
i mean but it's hard now though you know
now i mean like you know
it's just like it's just everywhere now
like you know what i'm saying like as
far as now i won't even say temptation
but as far as like the attraction of a
female attraction
sexual we're more of a sexual world
now than ever you know what i'm saying
yeah and i just think like
you know it's something that we're still
figuring out as a species
you know species of humans we're still
trying to figure this sex thing out i
think i think that's part of the
part of our issue like we still as a
civilization haven't figured out this
whole
control of yourself and sex you know
yeah that's
what i'm saying yeah absolutely human
beings and animals probably too
had did anything sexual you could do
with a human being an
animal you can't imagine anything that
hasn't been done to a human being in an
animal sexually
so what's the next level of sex it's
probably not having sex
probably not having sex it's so to
master yourself to have it to not have
it
to master yourself having an emotion
between one another without having
physical activity yeah to master that to
match that strength of you know to see
something more in a person
you know what i'm saying or something
more because sex sex just man especially
being young
sex just it just you know you know
that's why women is you know
so you know they'd be upset because they
just looked at it you just
you know when you're looked upon as a
sexual object all your life
you know what i'm saying it's hard to
communicate no no because people use
that for their power too so we can't
look at it for that perspective anybody
can use that
money to use it definitely use it for
their power but how do you
how do we use it they power on me i
don't know how do we use [ __ ]
perspective it's done um
it's just no way to think about it like
you said don't have sex i think
don't have sex like of course you have
sympathy but but just kind of like
kind of go deeper than than the sex go
deeper in a person
than the sex yeah i mean you just come
to a place i think where you realize
that the physical
act of sex is
you know unless it's with a person who
you connect with on that
emotional level it's sort of a it's a
trivial experience in your life
it's really something real complex too
because sex is something that doesn't
have to be taught
you know to do it yes it's primal yeah
lower
it's a lot of fantastic lowest but it's
a lot of fantasy it's a lot of
pre-thinking it's a lot of you already
you know i'm saying it's not it's it's
more it's more subconscious than it is
actually having it because
you know that's where porn comes in and
that's where you know what i'm saying
because right
because you're thinking you know what
i'm saying you know you ever
you have been with a chick and thought
about someone else because she just you
know saying thought about someone else
like you ever yeah you ever did that
no i um
i had sex with a girl and i know whether
i won a lost
what you mean like i know well
i can't handle her really yes
really yeah what yeah
really yeah holy [ __ ]
that's crazy me me it's like
i had i don't know i don't want to call
it a sexual addiction you know i want to
call it that but it's just like you know
i just have an appreciation for beauty
so i see beauty in everything
like you know what i'm saying like i
just don't have a type like because i'll
see beauty in something and nowadays
i just want a nice person at this point
in my life like
i just was looking i see i made the
mistake of looking at women as objects
and
and try to think that you know that i'm
going to really be able to find someone
you know like i was just fooling myself
you know you can't look at women as
objects and think you're going to be
loved the proper way
or give love the proper way so it's only
you know i'm saying
it took me a while to realize this man
you know what i'm saying that it really
is about
you know what i'm saying it took me a
while and you could say yeah okay of
course after all these years of
but i mean listen you know i'm saying as
long as you figure it out because i
could pass it to my sons
you know what i'm saying it's just that
it's not all about the sex like
now that it hasn't been like that you
can really dig deep into somebody
because with me and looking at somebody
man you want to [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what i'm saying and
then that that becomes priority and that
become that takes over
everything yeah and then when they leave
you all you're thinking is man
somebody's gonna be [ __ ] my [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying it's just
everything revolves around the [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying that's you know
what i'm saying so
i had to i had i know what you're saying
i had to check myself to really like if
i'm ever going to really be in love or
give the proper love to a proper woman
i have to not look at her as a sexual
object
absolutely it's the only it's the only
way it'll never work
on any other way yeah well i think a lot
of men
are dealing with that right now you know
i think a lot of men have that struggle
you know because
you know it's culturally it's just sort
of
been we've been brainwashed into this
in into these roles in our genders you
know men and women
you know so relationships and and our
growth with one another because you know
you think about when you first met and
you you guys may compassionate
passionate living you appear to be
overwhelming and
oh god damn baby don't daddy stop and
then eventually
you're not the same no keep it coming
you don't do that no more
you know have you ever have you ever had
sex with a woman and just okay you know
you just met
her and you had sex and you just i love
you
absolutely absolutely 10 minutes just
20 minutes
you met somebody 20 minutes i've been
winning for six years
yeah yeah i met him for 20 minutes in my
limo and we were thinking
we hung out for six years wow dude i
envy that too man i see y'all happy and
that's the man that's that's something
we've been through a lot yeah but y'all
and we've been together for years you
know i mean that's on the first
wing thing nobody introduced us anything
so let's just dissect that for a minute
yeah
you meet a person you're having sex with
her and you say i love you to her while
you're having sex you're looking her in
the eyes
okay now to you you're saying that
from from a place of the sex to her
she's hearing that
she's like whoa it's affecting her
different so now
you understand what i'm saying because
women are more frustrated you gotta find
out who they are first but
from who is she what does she experience
has she been [ __ ] um
wounded from a deserted father has she
been molested by her uncle who is she
when she hears that word what do you
you know where she goes to her where she
comes where do i come from when i say it
who am i what kind of guy am i right my
mother's a prostitute my father's a pimp
so me saying that word could be game or
could it be my only
real feeling of love yeah right i mean
that
that's a lie you see what he's saying
all those is what is it out of those
so you don't really know like you know
that's pleasure the pleasure feels so
good and you
i love you you know what i'm saying i
[ __ ] love you you know i mean like
yes i love you i'll kill for you
i don't want nobody else to touch you
and you just having sex with her so that
just is like man i said that in the car
don't give nobody to this [ __ ] person
she was like okay bye it's okay mike
take her home if you need this car stay
with you
that's just how it was we street [ __ ]
[ __ ] we get our women when we
grind you don't want nobody else to have
your [ __ ] man i understand that
but you got to take that out your head
now see now you can't do that especially
with social media
because now that because that that'll
get you behind see my father taught me a
few
things that was one of them he was
always at the penitentiaries and
cemetery
terry's a filled up because of women he
told me that years i mean years ago when
i was a kid but you got to look at it
because of men too there's a lot of
women doing a lot of time because of men
a lot of women getting cut up got acid
thrown in their face over some [ __ ]
men
yeah that's true women listen women do
more [ __ ] for us than we could ever
dream of doing for them yeah absolutely
i know
i get i got strung out a couple of times
and i know some people there's more [ __ ]
that i'd
for me stronger than i could ever
imagine doing for them strung out right
right you know i gotta just leave it
that's keeping it real they do some
really bizarre
[ __ ] oh even some really nasty stuff
somebody loves
hey i don't [ __ ] with women love she
said she love me
either i'm running on some stain one of
the uh
has love change from back in the day
to now has love the concept the word
change from back then because you know
because we're around the same age like
so you know
what love was as far as family a girl
you know
all the different aspects of it is it
the same love as it is now
yeah and i learned this because love
never changes
the feeling of what makes us what makes
that what makes us um
conjure the feelings once we hear that
word we don't know what that word is but
we know what the concept of what it
means
right why is it love why can't it be
[ __ ] why is going to be [ __ ]
why does it have to be love what does
love mean
well why why is that why you don't know
why is it love why is it that
why why can they why can it be why can
it be lascivious
why is it love who got that who
why is it love look and find out why the
love was it what's the essence of put
the essence of the great
question yeah let's look at that because
when people hear that word
it's almost life and death real it is
life it caused life
causes death it is love the essence
of true love is mutual trust and respect
towards one another
compassionate love is eternal rare and
enduring
love is kind patient and innocent it
never seeks revenge
it's like a poem we got to find a more a
more a more better
uh definition than that it got to be
something more deeper than that
love is not
love comes from like
where does it come from love is a form
of a thucker
lord no sucker for love naked rick james
no really
well the word love comes from the middle
english word
derived from the old english word
this is akin to old high german luba
and another old english word leof which
means
deer so i mean that
is just a upsetting uh
description the arbitrary word right
what is the original that's a good
question yeah what is the original
meaning of love
because it's still kind of it's still
kind of vague yo
love is when you choose to be at your
best that's from the huff post [ __ ] that
i mean i don't mind the millennium
[ __ ] that's super millennial
i mean i'm a millennial
love is also considered to be a virtue
representing human kindness now that's
okay you know it's the deepest human
kindness
really i like that really
but think about this mike
helen of troy yeah wars fought over
love [ __ ] [ __ ] if helen was involved
it was [ __ ] cleopatra [ __ ] wars have
been people have killed for love brutus
got killed of a [ __ ]
all of them [ __ ] we also have to look
at you see what he's saying
the perception of love right we also
have to think
right it's not necessarily love but it's
perception it was the [ __ ] yes
it's an obsession listen no really and i
don't want people to get mad at me and
[ __ ] youtube but nobody
[ __ ] listen right nobody don't be
honest you love your wife
yes think about loving her without a
[ __ ] deep
[ __ ] i'm about to man well i'll tell you
what
that was deep that was [ __ ] deep
i dreamed about my wife when i was seven
years old
didn't meet her until i was 18. we
didn't get together till i was
22 23
and when i think about
our relationship and all the [ __ ] we've
been through i
[ __ ] her up man during oh my time in
the nfl i don't know what time that you
know
i did a lot of damage and it's a
blessing that she's still
here here with me for you to say that
that's me give me something
and that's how i feel thanks brother and
i feel that way you know
yeah i know you do and hearing and
seeing
my wife didn't have a [ __ ] i would
still be with my wife yeah
because she's being what it was it's
like a soul
just it's like a soul contract for me we
are spiritually
connected beyond this beyond this realm
i believe that men have women for men
women to assure us to make sure that
we're men
we need absolutely men and that's you
know another reason
like my wife is
my perfect yin and yang dude you know
everything that i'm not good at
she's amazing at she's [ __ ] she's an
amazon woman you know she's hard as
[ __ ] nails
but loves me does everything for me
like you were saying mike has done more
for me than i could ever dream of doing
for her
very fortunate i know and i see that and
you know that's why and listen i'm
married and i gotta be
honest right if i did if my wife did
my wife did two one thing that
of the hundreds of things i've done i
wouldn't be with her
ain't that a [ __ ] i know brother
my wife i love my but my wife did to me
what i've done
i wouldn't love it right oh i wouldn't
well then maybe that would be love then
so maybe
so maybe love has to do with that maybe
love has to understand
all these things that's why i know my a
lie
if it is a wife connection then they
wouldn't go yeah
i just i can't believe that that's why i
had to because she's not going to want
to go no
she's going to hold on to the very last
and then you got to hold on to to the
very last you have to know what i
learned
you have to learn hey y'all are lucky
man you got to forgive yourself
man y'all making me feel bad over here
no brother [ __ ]
everybody's just saying man boy that's
the type of love i would love
you know what i'm saying honestly for
real like i've been saying yeah i've
been searching for that
i'm saying real it's a [ __ ] too
dude of course sometimes you're just in
there with the fire breathing dragon no
but i've been
through it's just that i'm saying when
you conquer that that's what i'm saying
like you're always gonna go through that
but
once you but if she's if she still
sticks with you throughout all that
that's
that's the ultimate warrior [ __ ] right
there man listen i remember you know
when i was
doing my thing and being i couldn't get
turned down i said i told a good please
just turn me down maybe i want your
number please say no please say no okay
and i still get the number i was just so
arrogant of cocky and [ __ ]
if you've ever done boxing kickboxing or
even thought about learning how to box
but you're too busy or just can't get
access to a good boxing gym
you definitely need to check out fight
camp you know they provide
everything to you so start boxing from
home that means amazing at home boxing
equipment
along with the new boxing and body bag
that's awesome
workouts released every week try fight
camp for 30 days
if you don't like it i love it i'll
return your money back train like a
fighter man
and turn your sweat into results join
fightcamp.com
slash tyson join fightcamp.com
slash tyson i'm in the house let's do it
to be great at something you got to have
the right woman who can allow you to be
great at that because it takes a lot of
time and effort and everything
absolutely and if they and now with
social media you know
they they're going to want their chaos
yeah
yeah okay okay i don't know we don't
know what is greatness you know what
greatness is
the definition of greatness has always
been in my head
somebody that could do something that is
so tremendously hard with the simplest
of ease
that's greatness that doesn't have to
practice for it now no you have to work
for it right
i do every [ __ ] day probably three
times a day to get that [ __ ] art down
but you do something that's so difficult
with the [ __ ]
simplest of these yeah you know that's
what people get paid for
you knock the [ __ ] out and how
long three seconds what
do it again what again yeah this is the
[ __ ]
nobody complained about that yeah like
people would complain man wow we want to
you know
everybody couldn't wait to see him knock
out they wanted what
people wanted mike to knock him on 10
seconds you know what i'm saying yeah
paid all that money number 10 seconds go
home just you know what i'm saying see
that [ __ ] just stoked
yeah cause cause for real people
understand the people like
those fights were really like i mean a
minute and less and it's like you know
minutes
so you're paying just for minutes you
know every other sport you're paying for
you know an hour and a half i know you
understand like after the fight you get
it off you're in the [ __ ] dressing
room now you're [ __ ] all cool chill
like you thought they [ __ ] [ __ ]
you didn't even break a sweat and you're
gonna play that [ __ ] on the television
you could play got the tokens in the
dressing room they rewind that [ __ ]
you get the highlight going to knock out
[ __ ] get that [ __ ] don't
look at that you talking [ __ ] in the
dress
that's probably the best you feel
that whole time right yeah but no it's
so weird
it's just weird after it's all over now
you're another human being you know
people are still cheering but wow yeah
it's over it's gone now what
now we got that's to you but in people's
last forever
forever yeah because it keeps happening
yeah see what i'm saying it keeps
once you know what i'm saying it just
keeps happening every three months
you know what i'm saying it was another
one it just stays in your head so what
do you think
what do you say you're 53 right 54 50
i'll be 54
listen do you ever think to yourself
woman like we all think this stuff
sometimes i'm talking i'm like
i'm talking i may be in my [ __ ] nice
house and she looking at my [ __ ] big
screen and i see myself
whoa i'm 50 [ __ ] three this [ __ ] is
almost over
now [ __ ] no [ __ ]
that hell no you ever think no way no
i haven't i really haven't why does it
whoa this [ __ ] i ain't going
no it's gonna be another 54 no it's
gonna happen when i got
done playing in the nfl i woke up one
morning and i was like
holy [ __ ] yeah i'm 30.
what the [ __ ] happened i feel like
yesterday i was in high school
you're never gonna die man your mind
like you'll never know it well physical
death i'm talking about from the
philippines
but even yeah but even you won't even
know that when you go you're not gonna
know it no that's why i just my mind is
my mind is just
it's just here and now like when you're
coming you know that's a great way to be
here
when you're going no because i've been
through so much i mean that's a great
way to be
so you want to live that's what you're
living today when you're just in the
moment i swear to god
tomorrow good or bad yeah i just i just
deal with today because a lot comes with
today
yeah bills issues kids situations this
that the third women
today is what you want to deal with and
then tomorrow you know what i'm saying
and then you want to keep trying to
build like i don't i can't
if you start thinking like that then
damn then that over does
set in like that over [ __ ] and believe
it or not you start getting i believe
the more you start thinking about old
and all that [ __ ]
the more you be old yeah as long as you
can live within your means just don't go
that there's just within your means you
know you don't have to go without your
means i think
my mistakes was just not just living
past my means but just trying to bring
everybody just give everybody but
living pasture means you know you don't
need a
a big 70 million acre house and it's
three of you
yeah you know what i'm saying like yeah
for real like real talk because you're
not even gonna be in the rooms half the
time so you're gonna
you're gonna have a house where you're
not even gonna be in the rooms so it's
like you really just gotta just
you know i'm saying okay i you know you
know just have money
you know what i'm saying put it make
sure bills are paid and just
understand that whatever you got going
that's bringing in money you know what
i'm saying make sure that that's going
because
if that stops you're gonna have
something put away to keep you going if
you're
used to a certain lifestyle see with me
it's just funny with me man because i've
had
millions and i've had nothing i've had
street money
i just never felt it like i've never
felt different i've never
felt like yo i just would spend it spend
the spending spending spending spending
spending
and then i but i've never felt i just
never felt different from money i've had
money didn't have money
it's just like it's the hustle with me
see i'm just a hustler so no matter what
i'm gonna keep hustling
and i realize growing up you know
you got to be a people person and you
can't be mean mugging you can't be
and it's like you know i'm saying yes so
i had to grow up and i had to realize
that a lot of
[ __ ] i was doing back then like if i'm
going to be in this business
that's not the way to be and you got to
check yourself you got to you got to
change yourself in the way you [ __ ]
it's you know be because you're going to
be with people who don't know that type
of behavior and it's going to be
it's going to close doors so man i
learned a lot
so now you know i'm in a great space to
where i figured it all out you know
i hope so i wonder i think wow what's
going to happen with my family because
i'm saying we're coming back from you
know you're going to be straight mike
i wanted to stay the way it is you know
you're doing great things man
and it's dope like well then she's the
one like you got to investigate
the toad is uh ancient medicine
it's five meow dmt you smoke it
i've heard that you have an ego death it
goes to the pineal gland
yeah yeah you know more than [ __ ] yeah
no i watched the the of the doors
oh yeah the movie yeah yeah
oh
but i got to be around people that do so
next time y'all do y'all let me know
just yeah you know what i'm saying yeah
i do want to go to you know i've i've
also seen it on tv a couple of times but
it takes you to a different dimension
and i i need to go there i got some
things i need to listen let me
see for sure imagine if you if that
feeling lasts for like an
hour imagine being in that dimension for
now your
experience well that's time travel i was
gonna say that's time travel traveling
that's time travel yeah this is 20
minutes you get 100
like 100 100 000 years of experience in
15 minutes coming at you fast it's crazy
yeah that's yeah i gotta yeah i want to
say i need to fail that
i need to feel like you know i'm the
type of person that could take that in
you might go
wow
you know what i'm saying i need to see
some [ __ ] like that i think you'd be
you'd you'd have a good time i'd have a
good time what did you see
when you did it i haven't done the toad
but i've done dmt
i've done the step below it so there's
dmt and then there's five
meow dmt yeah well i want to do the dmt
yeah i wanna i wanna do like you do i
wanna go
i wanna you want the riverboat ride
rather than the spaceship
yeah let me work my way in
you just get on the [ __ ] spaceship
and blast off [ __ ]
feeling yeah let me do this let me do
the first because i got to pull the
tape again like come get me please put
cold towels that sounds so awful man we
gotta do it
we gotta do it in the jungle though oh
yeah gotta like
well i think he's gonna take a little
bit mike i think we should take a little
retreat
down to the amazon oh that's gonna be
[ __ ] crazy blow your mind
yeah right now you see you've been
through everybody you traveled all over
the world you've been probably ever kind
of women beautiful but then when you
take the toll
they told you you have been nowhere
you've seen nothing you have been with
nobody
yeah i need to feel that that sounds
that sounds like something
i'm telling you it shows you how small
you are yeah i need compared to the
world
you're nothing you're not even a seed
you're smaller than a [ __ ] seed
wow wow it's a trip man it changes your
perspective you know
and you gotta have that yeah you gotta
throughout life well ancient cultures
knew this stuff
you know people start going insane
because they get stuck in the same old
routine and rigmarole and their habits
take over their life
so ancient cultures knew about the human
experience and they would use these
medicines
to you know go to the get to the next
level how did they know to get the
medicine from the toad or the plant how
did they know who told them
well in this book called the cosmic
serpent this guy spent
years with this tribe in the amazon and
talking to their shamans they said that
the plants teach us these things
right and for thousands of years this
knowledge has just been passed down
they'll fast from sex
food even water for a year
straight and they'll just take every day
they'll take
dmt and they're just out in the jungle
living off the land
for a year and they're literally
you know toggling between the spirit
realm and the physical realm
you know and learning all of this
information
well i mean the amer the indians were
doing that yeah absolutely
every culture had their own thing you
know it was peyote
ayahuasca the toad uh
mushrooms opium sure in china opium
right now
you remember you see a lot of people
don't know that they had dens in new
york where
people would go for a long time
businessman everybody go and just sit
down it's like an
empty smoke opium you know for real
yeah smoke opium yo well that's it
that's what's interesting about um that
19
marijuana tax act 1937 because uh you
know laguardia
he was the mayor of new york fiorello
laguardia
theorellio fiorello
guardian so the 1937 marijuana tax act
came down
and he had about 300 hash parlors
in new york city so he was like when
this [ __ ] hit
he he had you know a bunch of angry
business owners knocking on his door
going
yo what the [ __ ] now our shit's illegal
[ __ ] so he put together a whole board of
all the
smartest doctors and researchers that he
could find
and they put together the laguardia
report to prove that cannabis
was totally safe and a valuable medicine
and product and here we are today dude
and you've got your own brand yeah
look at that [ __ ] thing dude boss
genetics from the guys on this the
benzene og
so this is your company ben yeah man i'm
over here man and you know i mean
man it's a long time coming working with
the guys over at boss genetics
um a man joey and jesse you know
joey jeff you know joe you know what i'm
saying so you know check it out man got
some things coming out you know a lot of
pens and yeah man i'm excited about it
you know what i'm saying i'm excited
finally
i can finally get a strand and finally
get my name you know o.g cali buzz the
whole crew so
i'm excited about it you know what i'm
saying [ __ ] beautiful packaging
come on [ __ ] tell me your name your
stuff man this is um
boss status genetics this is the benzene
benzene og
gasolini did you know that ducktales
there was a
uh a guy named benzino gasolini oh
yeah a [ __ ] character you could
google them
benzeno gasoline
images there he goes look at him you see
him with the scarf over there
yeah he's a player oh gasoline bro
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and he's a pig yeah i don't like that
like
i like making the italian the pig
how did you get the name benzino yeah oh
man my
mom you know my man trevor he's locked
up free trev but um you know i used to
be free twice
um yeah man trevor is like benching five
something man you
know what i'm saying doing his thing man
you know what i'm saying don't hurt
yourself [ __ ]
yeah yeah he gave me he gave my name it
went from ben it went from ray dawg i
was ray dog with the almighty rso
and it went to uh to benzino and [ __ ]
because you know i was in the hood and i
was
every you know benzes yeah
[Music]
let me ask you a question what what
hip-hop was you listening to
was you listening to hip-hop when you
when you was fighting for the olympics
and who do you remember who you was
listening to four years what
was that what would you listen to
yourself i didn't make the
olympic trials around that time where i
was doing who was i listening to i was
listening man
run dmc i was listening to the fat boys
and stuff like that slick rick and these
guys
that's all you listen to was hip-hop or
did you listen to disco
um the disco r b and some smooth ass
[ __ ] rock and roll i mean real
[ __ ] rock and roll was rock and
roll
in that realm sing it you go to frank
nah
[ __ ] frankie lyman and all those guys
man
you go to um elvis presley when he had
fly ass
oh yeah did you box to music because
there wasn't really no headphones so
um so yeah yeah man brought you guys
thank you mr
boss i'm saying turn that thing on
yeah um yeah i shadow box through the
music
and we listen to the um [ __ ] um so
would they bring out a speaker like how
like how
did you know i'm saying what was that
this is what normally i would bring my
boombox
yeah all kinds of [ __ ] from homeboy that
made the tape for me and stuff everybody
you missed that you missed cassettes in
that whole ever that whole cassette era
you know what i'm saying
cassette tape mixed tape tapes and [ __ ]
no because it was very
listen no it's really a fun thing it was
novelty it was
fun right but it was always in the way i
had so many of them when you got about
you got 300 to 400 [ __ ] cassette tape
yeah
yeah i know and you gotta look and you
gotta put them down to find the one you
want you gotta go
and then if my mom said get the [ __ ] out
the house or something
[ __ ] you know when you're kidding me i
know it's [ __ ] like music i remember
eight tracks
i remember eight tracks my father had a
war eight track
and um bill cosby comedy a track i'd
never forget those would you remember
with a fat albert gang on it i never on
the a track
i remember when we used to rob the cars
we need to take the eight tracks
um [ __ ] a track show today tracks
eight tracks just didn't make it through
cassette tapes
is that what happened cassette tapes
took over the sets came out came out you
know why
because the eight track was too [ __ ]
big
it was like a videotape it was a new
house it's like a vhs right it wasn't
reliable
it wasn't a good but the eight track
covers were
lethal like classic the covers are oh my
god
it was like the same kind of as a vch
right yeah my uncle was huge my uncles
had all these incredible records so i
used to love going through that
record yeah long playing those are long
playing joints yeah
yeah it's beautiful man that's kind of a
shame because you don't get that anymore
i'll be brought streaming listen we used
to rob me my man two times man
used to rob colleges for all their
records we had a ten thousand collection
of records wow
we would steal all the colleges all the
colleges out of the record player always
throw the record
i was in my grandfather's basement when
i was about man it probably was like in
77
and uh to be real and the original
apache
down i'm saying down down down down
and the song called sex remember that
down there down there
sex it was the same it was by the bongo
brothers or the bongo band
but anyways that was the first joints i
learned how to scratch on i was in my
own
my uncle eddie's basement and he had he
had bruce lee
um posters he had a cb radio remember cb
radio man number that i was the phantom
my father would make me
he was in a fed he he he would make me a
belt
like in in leather class like in the
feds called the phantom i remember all
that [ __ ] man
for real i remember that i would be
remembering a lot but i remember that
like that was like early like i love
hip-hop that's fun man you ever see wild
style
no beach street yeah
you [ __ ] with crazy legs you know um
listen um
my my wife she's a friend of mine
her uh her makeup artist marries one of
the dancers out of crazy legs crew okay
rocksteady out of rock steady steady
crew they live in
vegas yeah legendary that's crazy dude
dj in history was bad dan
it was just [ __ ] beautiful yeah they
were crazy like this was a [ __ ]
problem
the puerto rican guy they were off the
hook they had like one
that they had one brother there yeah i
think he was just as he spun on his head
i forgot him
mr freeze tell us about the source
awards man
source awards tell us brother how did it
even become how did you start
well you know i think about it source
magazine dave mays you know i'm saying
the whole staff i mean five mikes
legendary [ __ ] it was just right that
you know because the grammys was jerking
[ __ ] so much back then that uh
figured like look man we need our own
you know what i'm saying yeah and at
that time i mean it started really on
your mtv raps as just a read-off
that was like the first one you know
what i'm saying that was like the first
source awards was a read-off
you know it wasn't even an awards show
but then we did the first one in um
and uh at madison square garden in the
theater area
and um god rested dead bernie back
hosted it
wow saying the first joint um wow yeah
that's it hosted that the first the
light the lights were [ __ ] up it was
it was raw though you know what i'm
saying
yeah it was crazy like it was a lot of
iconic moments and so swords but it was
just a
you know really a collaborative idea of
that we just felt like you know
um that that's what it needed at that
time you know i'm saying like hip-hop
needed it
to be recognized you know because like i
said the grammys really wasn't
recognizing hip-hop
and hip-hop was such a strong uh you
know strong music and it was a strong
infusion of to the culture that it
needed yeah something just to represent
hip-hop and a lot of times people
were really scared to deal with these
artists anyways so we didn't you know
you know what i'm saying mike came to
you know i'm saying fuel
um the rappers now have become pretty
much um
what do you call them um domesticated
now compared to the ones in the 80s yeah
well then wasn't it the first time
people got to see this east coast west
coast feud i mean that was
that was iconic but people don't
understand like
you got it like you know even beyond
what happened with the
when it happened when sure got up and
said what he said and then every like
i i look at the um if you look at those
performances the performances were
amazing oh yeah here's the first time
you got to see
really the whole entire bad boy crew
like everybody on one stage and then the
whole entire death row with
everybody on stage together so just that
alone to me was i remember watching it
you know
i mean the the the the the part was
that you really thought that at any time
it was getting ready to go down like i
did
yeah you know i thought that it was
going down because i mean they were deep
they were deep from the west coast
and they were in new york so new york
was deep
so i thought it was going down but i
think i think hip-hop
i think hip-hop saved it and i think
when snoop got up there and said what he
did kind of saved him when he said
he kind of grabbed the mic and was like
yeah ain't got love for you know he
caught that was a
kind of a lot of people don't understand
that was a kind of a defiant defining
moment
that he kind of brought the tension down
at that moment right there when he
grabbed the mic
amazing you know what i'm saying like
that was yeah yeah but we got through it
you know what i'm saying we always had
nation of islam security you know
wow wow mike did you ever meet thank you
minister ferguson i got to mr falcon did
you ever meet biggie
yeah twice what was he like
very cool yeah he's very cool he's super
chill
yeah and we were talking he came to my
house one day
and um i was having a party and he came
to the house and i said biggie doctor
i'd become coming so we're talking
she said because he's from brooklyn too
so yeah one of his friends named
[ __ ]
was a friend of mine you know back in
the 70s when we were kids like eleven
nine years ago we used to fly birds
together
and he said [ __ ] told me you fly
birds and stuff together yeah you know
[ __ ] then we discussed that i saw
him outside of a club one night
and then all this stuff started
happening i went like i went to prison
then all this stuff started
then by the time i came out you know
these guys started killing each other
you still fly birds yeah really are you
going to have the bird thing
on the ranch so people could actually
see it that's what they were thinking
about
i think that'd be dope you're gonna have
all that open air thinking about putting
some lines and tigers
everything sanctuary thank you beautiful
i think it'd be beautiful but the bird
thing with him doing
i think people would want to see that oh
yeah because you really are the only
person i've ever
even seen on video dude like period i
don't you know what i'm saying
was i've never seen no one else do that
what was the movie horace whitaker
i mean in the movies i'm talking about
i'm saying in movies
right but that's the movie i'm saying
yeah you know what i mean yeah
you know what i mean because i know they
do it in brazil a lot they do they do it
somewhere else
i thought i was looking somewhere in
there is it some kind of maybe it wasn't
brazil but it's some country
that they think why don't no i do have
pigeons they're very um very few people
don't have pigeons even like if you go
to um like the royal family in england
everybody they have pigeon coops too
because they're pitching races it's the
big money like
if you look up south african pigeon
racing yeah in cape
cape town stuff it's like three million
dollar race you still got pigeons oh i
keep until i die
really i'm always happy to die um
have you had one what's the longest ones
you've had for like one
how long then yeah i had about 17 years
old before
17 years yeah in the wild they don't
live that way no
from from what age to what age excuse me
from what age to what age did it was
i was a little kid i don't remember 17.
um
he had the band i didn't raise him but
he had the band he was marked
you know at that time so is there one
now you got that special
no they're all beautiful they thought
awesome you're going
to say [ __ ] i didn't know pigeons look
like this
yeah they all pedigree and they all know
you
pretty much yeah that's amazing you know
that's [ __ ] is that interesting
that's amazing man i let them out when
you let them out it's critical you see
it and they're locked up
but you let them out they go away in the
sky you can hardly see them they do
their stuff they come back and they go
in the coop and it's a wreck
so if you and your wife out of central
park the pigeons come up you
you you you [ __ ] with the pigeons out
there listen this is what i do
anywhere i'm at in the world i said i
betcha i can catch one of those birds i
figured
they give me um
the pigeons come down right right grab
them all without it
wow the most i did with a pigeon
throwing mcdonald's french fries in
boston common yeah
they love some [ __ ] french fries boys
they love it
they love it all the pigeons in the
world originate from the pigeons in the
streets
you know darwin took him like if he saw
one street pigeon or something
and he still had white in it one white f
he'll grab all the birds with white and
breed them together wow
and then they'll turn up one of them and
turn off solid white that's a street
dove
huh no it does the dove's opinion the
two different species that street though
that's a picture because the pictures
come from
dubs come from where like where do doves
come from um
dubs are the species of pigeons that's a
specie of pigeon
i didn't know that's interesting but if
they breed together the baby comes out
sterile
huh yeah the baby can't have babies
interesting
baby between the pigeons charles darwin
did that huh
charles darwin did so much for pigeons
you know interesting
i didn't know that the galapagos islands
galapagos
yeah that's where you went to they're
really they really were used for like to
carry messages mainly since the
beginning of the time sometimes
enrollment times and stuff like that too
message crazy and then when they started
fighting with the arabs and stuff the
muslims the muslims started training
falcons
to intercept the pigeon and find that on
the get the [ __ ]
out of here yo hell no get out of here
yes
wow that's nuts yo okay we're gonna get
somebody
he's he's imagine the pigeon coming in
on his regular you know
the first time he's seen a falcon like
yo what up bro
the falcon guy sometimes the falcon has
to lay probably he waits for him or else
he's way in the air
and there's a guy he dives on because
it's very difficult to catch a pity very
added even though the falcons faster
he's very agile pigeon very hard to
catch so how far can a pigeon go to
carry a note
check it out good question
i did 100 miles easy 100 miles
get the [ __ ] out of here that's like
from boston to connecticut like
[ __ ] boston in new york is nothing to
them for a pigeon
nothing to carry a message nothing oh no
you bet
that's hard more like from [ __ ] to la to
new york tonight to probably give them a
run for their money [ __ ]
and maybe not even that you no other
pigeon um other pigeon
other pigeon people oh yeah all over the
world is that what they call pigeon
people what do you call
a pigeon fancier the flyers okay flies
there you go 60 miles per hour 100 miles
per hour [ __ ] in the hood loves
pigeons man like that
those are birds those are our parrots
that's all we've seen about pigeon right
no no mess with these pigeons and stuff
flights
as long as 1100 miles
that's just what's been recorded that's
only been recorded that means they go
farther
they go to damn near colorado from
[ __ ] i'm gonna go fly
at nighttime they don't stop they can
see it now i thought they couldn't see
at nighttime they could see it at night
yeah
amazing how many pigeons you got
maybe maybe 1400 now i always say 2500
but we got rid of so many probably like
1300 damn
and they all like basically like they
they consider their home
they consider their home what this is
deep for me their house costs like
100 g's [ __ ] yeah that's my life i make
sure they're taking care of they always
cling to every day does the staff have a
[ __ ]
claim every day they leave they go but
no
professional man i'd hate to be the
staff loser
you tell them you know the first
fight mike was ever in was defending a
pitcher that's why he took my purge my
burden killed and ripped his head off
yeah i said i seen that when he still
did yeah
ripped his head off now look you know
there had to be you know he was just
born bad
whoever did that because you know i
don't think i was born bad you know
some [ __ ] are born bad like if you're
just gonna rip a [ __ ] pigeon's head
off
he wasn't born bad but that's just
what's the thing that's how you
disrespect him that's how the pigeon
world is yeah but there's other ways to
disrespect
god catch a bird like you're birds
you're burning birds clashes
so you catch the guy's burden this guy's
an [ __ ] cause he caught a couple of
your birds
probably during the week of last year or
something and he said [ __ ] you
[ __ ] i got your
boom yeah that's a different dude he
needed psychiatry
i bet you're waiting that's the game
that's the pigeon game [ __ ] the pigeon
game is vicious people been shot
throwing off rules over ripping yeah
[ __ ] just whip off they [ __ ]
like with no
listen right the [ __ ] listen guy has his
birds out you got your birds out
all of a sudden he thinks that you know
you went to work or something he left
his new birds out
you [ __ ] wait and his birds are
flying you run up to your coop you let
your birds out
catch these new birds [ __ ] he calls my
new birth he waits for you to come
downstairs and he hit you over the
[ __ ] head with a bad damn
it's intense pigeon wars the kids real
in the picture
pigeon wars do you breed them you also
breed them
absolutely absolutely i stopped
breathing because we got too much but my
friends gave 25 to my other friends so
we're going to start breeding again
do you do do you give them away or sell
them or do you like what are you um no
i do um my friend tells me that he needs
some birds or something i send 50 or
something birds down there
he'll breed them and stuff and um
this is what's interesting about birds
so if i got 2 000 birds right
and i have to sell my birds i'll sell my
birds so some of them are
you know i'll sell them like they say i
want to get rid of two dozen birds right
i sell for what
20 bucks a whop 10 bucks a whopps but i
got 2 000 birds
all right so i got doing what a hundred
and something birds here
now i'm gonna do a hundred and something
birds to another factory or to another
um auction here so you so you so you use
flipping birds literally
yeah literally flipping birds
he was liberty you know what i'm saying
you be talking the feds how you should
tap yeah
listen i need five birds yeah you don't
say always
i need
yeah these guys have two hundred
thousand dollars in their birds these
guys these guys
these guys don't work they're hustlers
they got 20 000
on that roof and like i was saying
before most of people started the
guys that in the the dark world the
gangsters all the mothers from the
beginning of time they all had pigeon
coops
all of them lucky lucian all those guys
they all have blue birds
everybody flew birds and and the way you
clapped is that that's the that's the
language if you train them that way
got you some people training whistle
someone with the clap how do you you
you like clap yeah
it's interesting do you name them have
you named them not really because i
don't try to get too attached to them
because they're going to die it's a
hawkers go again and i'm going to be fat
right right you know and you have been
sad of course always sometimes i cried
over these birds
sometimes the guy's too big he takes my
birds from there's nothing i can do you
know the big guy
if you ever had somebody call your
bird's arrest that's the biggest insult
that's cause for fighting
i have i was getting somebody to tell us
when later that he's like man look at
you though
dirty ass rats get them out of here
that's big time disrespect because of my
birthright that's very offensive
wow interesting yeah you don't know
what's going to come back after that
it's like that in the streets too might
take it back yeah you don't know what's
going to happen after that
yeah benzene do you have anything like
that
a rabbit had a rabbit did a rabbit had a
[ __ ] rabbit clover wow yeah when i
was doing love in hip-hop i had a rabbit
yeah
yeah i taught the rabbit how to [ __ ] in
a kitty litter
nice that was pretty cool that's good i
used to uh i used to call the rabbit
jump in my lap
sweet was it one of those big ones
i mean i got a flemish i got her as a
thing but then then she grew you know
what i'm saying i was like it was all
white bunny and i just for some reason i
thought khloe kardashian i don't know
why i just named it chloe you like
huh like chloe oh you know i man you
know
chloe's nice chloe's cool yeah chloe's
cool you know what i'm saying yeah
clayton i mean
yeah chloe's i mean like i said i find
beauty in everything mike
you know what i'm saying i find beauty
in everything man i think women are
beautiful species
they're beautiful species when god what
well i guess they said the women came
from
the rib is that no that's not dude we're
going to get in trouble
don't say that well i was going to say
god made a woman he
he no [ __ ] god is god of them
transgender [ __ ] god is part woman in
part man all right so
god made women he know women is made
yeah because what yeah
i'm trying to be political correct no
one want to hear i came from a nigga's
rib they don't listen to that no i
didn't know
that was i was gonna say god god broke
the mobile women
i didn't know even religious preaching
women i'm not from the
[ __ ] i like it i like that god broke
the mold with women that's right that's
why he likes that
yeah because i mean think about it women
women are beautiful man
women are beautiful man oh women of god
my life would not women
interesting huh women are beautiful it's
like the most beautiful is artwork and
everything but you know
i don't think no art anything can can
top a woman like
women of the are the epitome of beauty
you know what i'm saying i mean you see
a woman you just be
wow i mean i mean a woman's beauty would
just take you over just here take it all
i mean we all love beautiful women
absolutely so you got your cannabis
brand
you're also opening up a restaurant he
had some of her don't you
well yeah i had opened it benzino's crab
trap awesome
atlanta benzino's crab trap yeah yeah
yeah they're located
it's gonna be in the south dakota mall
open up in the as we're gonna have a
grand opening uh definitely
yeah how do you do that no more how do
you put a restaurant on the mall tell me
how this [ __ ] well um
these people had actually i was in l.a
and i would be how could i work in a
mall or if i'm not
i'd be all over the [ __ ] no it's gonna
be dope man like um
the mall had flew me down there they had
heard about the one i had did in
marietta georgia
awesome and man yeah you know um all the
all the sauces and recipes how's the
food good
all the recipes are mine oh i know i i
got lines out the door it's incredible
bro it's all on my grave i'm carly
feeling about that
who the car no mike that's carly's old
that was
years ago
i want to be a part of some kind of way
again you know what i don't even know
man it's like one thing i think
the land of that big where my [ __ ]
disappear you won't see him it is you
know what it is there's a lot of trees
it's not that's that big but it's just
it is it's spread out in its trees
so it ain't all you see out la
everything's out and open
atlanta man you could be a couple of
miles away it's just so many trees you
won't see it yeah for months you know
what i'm saying
yeah everybody talking about [ __ ] with
a bunch of black [ __ ] on you 24
7 of a day
um i love it i love you know i'm just so
i'm
you know me my mr hood [ __ ] like i've
been through again i've been through so
much to where it's a blessing
that i could still get love and you know
so you know i love that i ain't gonna
front like
i'll be more happy let me take a picture
with you yeah come on you know i'd be
more happy to take one with them you
know
listen man you gotta [ __ ] experience
a [ __ ] black city there's nothing
like this [ __ ] atlanta's dope
[ __ ] yeah la's dope miami's dope i mean
boston
every city got something different you
know that every place got something
different
i gotta be in a quiet [ __ ] city at
this point in your life
at this stage in my life to get the best
out of me i need to be in the future
like newport beach
yeah right now i am
[ __ ] over this i'm ducked off over
this is no good no more
the business is shut down [ __ ] i can't
be in there like
no more [ __ ] type of brand i burnt
the [ __ ] fields
and [ __ ] tyson finish [ __ ]
they're out there
no but it's good like that love is good
oh you know it's good man like when
people
you know what i'm saying like yeah
because you know like [ __ ] after the
source
had failed and everything man we know
the feds it was an investigation and
[ __ ] was a whole big thing and like
pretty much lost everything you know i'm
saying so you know with me
i think it hit dave more than it hit me
because i'm from the street
so i'm gonna get back out there one way
the other
and get it with dave he went to harvard
and um you know his parents you know i'm
saying i'm sure they
they they was probably they they look
they probably want it they didn't want
that to happen
so maybe it's maybe do you think dave's
family said why are you [ __ ] with
these black [ __ ] man
no i'm just i'm i'm you know [ __ ] i
mean the reality of it is
but the reality of it is dave comes from
an old school jewish family so you know
you just
i mean if that's how they felt you just
have to respect that and it doesn't
bother me because me and dave's
relationship
was always a one so you know it's it's
it's you know i mean you would like
you would like you know you would like
everybody to love each other in it but
if it don't you know we still taking
care of business you know what i'm
saying it's just
[ __ ] i mean
[Laughter]
you guys have fun in that [ __ ] source
place man it was i was out of control
man
i believe it man it was [ __ ] that was
the show
they were talking about magazine being
being in south beach was great back then
right and it was out of control man i
confronted i used to have hotel rooms
like three penthouses just right there
waiting just with all the keys right
there just
you know what i'm saying like it was i
know it was out of control and then i
had a club benzenos and
i just me i gave away more bottles than
probably i didn't even make no money i
lost a couple of million on the club
i can't just take miami either you like
the bgs
bg the [ __ ]
young brother andy he was even bigger
than him in the od yeah yeah
man their [ __ ] songs would be he had
victoria principal back then remember
she found she was the one on dynasty
victoria dallas whatever she was she was
dope she was dope gloria
you love saturday night fever tell the
truth
that was the movie [ __ ]
that was the movie staying in line that
was the [ __ ]
that was the [ __ ] dude how'd you feel
when he the first time you see him and
he jumped off the bridge
remember listen man i thought the
[ __ ] committed suicide too yeah
but when the guy fell off the bridge
what are you saying i knew that was
coming it was coming oh you know what's
coming
i knew somebody was going off the bridge
right it was it was [ __ ] around
yeah yeah that was the [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
man see that was dope because you know
that movie's right there we could talk
about those movies
they're movies i don't know what they
did in boston like sam sam 10 years old
nine years old right
we go with like what about 15 guys right
from brownsville we get on the train to
see we go all the way up to 42nd street
and then we get [ __ ] terrorized we
were going to [ __ ]
listen we were just going to cartoon you
know what a train you going to train
of course yeah you're going to train we
had the orange red line
we went on the train with our crew [ __ ]
the doors closed we take we robbing
everyday smashing everybody
robbing ripping it see new york trains
are different we're off the [ __ ]
yeah new york trains young kids off the
hook snatching purses chains
people's neck beating the [ __ ] out of
them the door open we are gone the next
stop
yeah new york trains are different yeah
that's real [ __ ] no no for real because
how many cars would be on the new york
train it'll be eight of them ten of them
right
seeing boston is you know i mean you
could do all and then then you're going
for
like you're going yeah you can do all
that [ __ ] like new york trains you have
once the new york train is going you
can't the door is closed you can sit and
now
stop the next stop if you don't have no
weapons that's like five minutes
sometimes
ten minutes [ __ ] you [ __ ] seen the
warriors
yeah right oh yeah okay so i got this
movie i did
all right you love the warriors well
it's awesome what about doing
the rise of cyrus and show how cyrus
take it before he got shot remember you
don't say it and show him how he ran the
gangs
so it would go all the way up until to
the
the end it would be how he because
that's how it's going it would be the
prequel
yeah the rise of cyrus yeah it'd be dope
right or something
he knew karate because his his boys was
at the dojo remember yeah
in the 70s that's what it was [ __ ] i
was the [ __ ] [ __ ] with
so we would go watch it this is new york
anybody from new york would know this is
true especially from brooklyn
we would um skip school go to 42nd
street in times square
um one person will pay to go on a movie
open the back door and let the rest of
us in
right we're getting the movie theater
and we watch the karate
oh [ __ ] and it really doesn't matter
next thing you know
we start getting upside down we stand up
get out of our seats in the movie
we see somebody there and we say whoa i
mean just give him a [ __ ] kick in
that booth
robbing him and that's just what we did
i'm living well my fam i think i used to
raw people and i still love it
that was the manipulate to pick their
pockets just go
rip their pockets out and just run it's
crazy we used to do house invasions too
oh we did that but we did a lot of
houses we would have a kid
and i learned this from the jamaican and
the west indian guys they would have a
key that doesn't have
no affiliation with the lock desk
they're breaking in the door and they
would they would just jam and play with
it and all of a sudden the door would
open
pop i said how did we used to go in
housing if the houses i mean
little seymour little see we're in the
house man that was the first time i've
seen there's no light heat in the
refrigerator
oh my god damn no we didn't get [ __ ]
there was times we didn't even get [ __ ]
out there some sometimes um
friends of mine there'll be three of
people and i see two of my friends they
start fighting because they start
snatching they don't want the rabbits to
have [ __ ] right they want the other
person to see god cause they don't want
to be the first place you got to go is
the bedroom it's the first place you got
it you know what i mean you gotta get
yourself
fashioned he tried to hide stuff not let
him know that he got something and they
start fighting in the [ __ ] house
you'll see in boston you have to [ __ ]
out that we're robbing the fight
in boston you have car thieves you have
housing va you have robbers you have you
know what i'm saying
it was everybody did something even like
car seat massachusetts was heavy for car
these back in the day
stealing cars yeah i was never into that
stealing cars
i mean they i mean they would just grab
them just to get chased
yeah just to get chased by police i mean
it was chill you didn't you'd be like
bank robberies big heavy bank robbers
heavy banker i like um charleston
charlestown you know the irish you know
what i'm saying
big time yeah yeah my dad was locked up
with a bunch of bank robbers from canada
you know what i'm saying uh so yeah like
bank robbers is heavy in boston too
there was a lot of banks in boston you
know what i'm saying um you know uh
armored cars
yeah you have to have nerves to do that
[ __ ] that's nuts
yeah i mean imagine imagine back in when
it was rob banks in the
in the midwest imagine actually because
there was no police
see when the midwest first started in
america baby yeah man the reason why
they was doing all that because
there was no police in the midwest like
it was just still nothing there there no
it wasn't nothing
one sheriff and no one else they were
more um they had more
uh artillery than the police yeah
baby faith notes tommy guns yeah and the
police had that bonnie and clown
they had [ __ ] smith and wesson six
shots smith and wesson and these guys
got tommy guns
that's why there was robin banks left
and right yeah and it took the the army
and the marshals to
to you know special guys to come get him
thank you thank you my brother melvin
purvis
melvin purvis he came to get a beast
he was the beast beast who other [ __ ]
melvin purpose was
that's why he did it because he was
getting too much love and that's why um
jaguar fired him
he committed suicide after that fenzino
man it's been great having you in
brother
this was dope bro thank you brother man
come anytime come anytime you're welcome
back man
thank you man great stories good [ __ ]
that was awesome man thank you so much
great weed now you gotta talk about the
[ __ ] that took the camera from remember
before
oh yeah okay this one is the last stop
all right so look i didn't even believe
he remembered he
told me that that's my one mike tyson
story so we had
we have my club mike comes in so mike's
[ __ ] up and [ __ ] so mike
grabs me and [ __ ] we in the vip section
he's grabbing and he's talking to me
so mike starts saying [ __ ] about
somebody 1804
and gangsters in providence he was
taught like he was he was getting deep
i just like i just was like tripping
like man mike tyson you know what i'm
saying this is dope
so then the dude came over and he came
the photographer and he put the joint in
his mouth like this
and he crossed his leg and he said you
and because he's trying to be and he's
like
next thing you know mike reaches over
grabs him because he had
the cord around by the [ __ ] thing
pulls them
cause the dude small poses [ __ ] like he
chokes him from the back with the cord
of the camera
pulls the thing takes the camera off
snaps the camera in half from the lens
he got one of them cannon cameras
threw the camera down the dude jetted
out i'm sitting there right
so i'm just sitting i ain't saying [ __ ]
so then i remember you saying like
that's the enemy and i was like all
right
he's the [ __ ] enemy you know what i'm
saying yeah like he's the enemy because
he got his arm around me he's right
there
he's the [ __ ] enemy wow [ __ ] right
you know what i'm saying come to find
out later on and this was years later
and um i found out that jay lash was don
king's photographer oh wow now
that's how it all made sense man did you
know that
i didn't know what the [ __ ] happened
that's crazy that was that's my
microphone
dude that's such a good one i can't
understand this [ __ ] remember that
that's [ __ ]
come on come on such a good story
[ __ ] champ bro it's awesome man well
thank you dude
thank you again in a million years now
you know i'm sorry yeah
you're so nice ain't nothing with that
you know what i'm saying
stories are dope though yeah
stories are dope hell yeah shout out
though jay lash we love you [ __ ] come
on buy more man
yeah man any time great app brother
hey awesome episode we're out of here
hey man check out
benzino's products genetics man boss
genetics
genetics.com you know what i'm saying on
their instagram you know what i'm saying
genetics you know i'm saying hi tv you
know what i'm saying we here baby
all right y'all we're out of here
helping purpose love hey mel
that never purpose was a beast yes he
was
[Music]
two